the startup program is going to be
shared thank you all for coming so we
have a means of very from Stanford
definitely the mic is working matching
is the most central problem in algorithm
design and combinatorial optimization it
has roots in the work of giants like
Euler and Kershaw it's been crucial in
the development of theory of computing
but we had welcomed notorious Edmonds
paper on finding matchings in general
graphs had also this developed this
notion of good algorithms what we call
now polynomial time algorithms Karp's
paper that reduced a few community
realizations problems to each other
problems that now we call NP complete or
np-hard had three dimensional matching
as one of the examples included there
and now with the advent of new
applications in online markets like
online advertising ride-sharing Android
hailing applications and federal other
matching markets for the allocation of
organs to patients students to schools
kids to foster homes we are facing a lot
of very a lot of new and interesting
applications of matchings and these
applications have also led to many
intriguing questions and difficult
challenging open problems one of the
interesting aspects of the markets here
is that they are dynamic in the sense
that the matching we need to find in a
graph the graph is not give
to us in one shot we get it in bits and
pieces and we have to make decisions
about you know who to match to home of
with partial information about the
future and that makes actually the
problem quite difficult
here is one application that two
applications that we are looking at so
here in this graph this is the life
expectancy or additional life expectancy
of someone who has a renal failure as a
kidney failure so someone in their
thirties and they have a kidney failure
they have about 10 years on dialysis so
essentially you have 10 years to find
out a match to find them a kid you know
if you make a request for rideshare
typically the app gives you a window so
says you know I'm gonna find a right for
you in three minutes or in five minutes
essentially it the app gives itself this
time to find the best right that's a
good match for your right and you know
use this window to improve the quality
of the matching so in both of these
applications we have every time we have
a request for a matching we have some
window we have a predetermined you know
sort of we have a fixed window in which
with one you know to find a match for
the request another thing that these two
applications have in common is that here
if you come up with an algorithm that
improves the quality of matching it
leads to you know increase life
expectancy improve quality of life again
a better algorithm for matching would
reduce the driving time reduce the
weight at time we'd use you know their
wasted time or again traffic and
pollution so in both cases you can
contribute the good alright so I'm going
to define a very simple formulation
tries to capture the essence of this
problem that I described to you
we're gonna have the graph G with n
vertices the graph is arbitrary the
weights are also RB no the for every
pair of vertices there is a weight
that's the value you will gain for
matching these two vertices to each
other the weights could be arbitrary to
essentially adversary chooses that once
the graph is determined vertices of the
graph arrive in a random order so every
time in every time a step and new vertex
arrives and then you have their steps it
stays in the system for dere steps so
essentially you have these steps to
match that vertex in other words two
vertices can be matched to each other if
the you know after you you know the
intervals in which they are present has
an intersection vertices come one by one
you decide you know who to match to each
other and then at the end you get some
matching and your goal is to maximize
the expected weight of the match it is
the problem clear know the information
is coming to you online
so the yeah you get the information one
by one every time a new vertex arrives
you can observe the weight of the edges
between that vertex and other vertices
that are present
and I'm gonna look at at the start I'm
going to look at a very simple policy a
very simple algorithm for matching these
vertices to each other we call them the
batching algorithm so the way it works
is that you wait for deer steps as soon
as the very first vertex that I have is
about to go you look at your market and
you find the maximum weight matching
there essentially you try to clear the
market then you wait another D plus 1
steps you see who else is present the
ones that you match or not match before
are gone you have a new set you match
those and you keep repeating this so
that that's what we call the batching
algorithm probably the simplest
algorithm you can think of for it it's
like you know for example in the context
of uber let's say every 10 20 seconds
you know right you know hailing
application can look at all the cars
that are present all the requests and
find the you know best matching no like
if you are the last person again there
are D plus D vertices before you that
you can be matched to so everybody has
the same degree in this graph right so
they have an advantage it will be
immediately matched so here I don't have
a cost for waiting yes they have to wait
longer yes I give them the match on that
sir yeah so you can no choices you can
think about cases where there is a
cancellation probability but it's not a
bid in the framework of this is the
question you know batching yield the
best competitive ratio for this problem
so what is the competitive ratio
competitive ratio is the worst case
ratio between the solution of the
algorithm over the optimum solution so
in this case you know you run your
algorithm you get some solution you will
get some matching it has a value then
you can think about Oh what if I knew
everything you know if like the arrival
of every vertex and I computed the
maximum weight matching then look at the
ratio of the two look at the worst case
over all possible instances over all
different graphs that would give you the
competitive ratio and the question that
we have is whether this is the best
thing you can do yes the earlier ones
cannot wait anymore so all their matches
are here so let's say you are in the
second batch and you're the first person
maybe your best batch just arrived
before you what a batch matched in a way
so so even the first vertex can say I
can have the same complet do you mean
match let's someone die
- right there's going to be some
expected you to benefit actually I'm
gonna give me a few minutes and then
what we'll see very nice problem the
answer to it oh this is the best thing
we can do we say the batching algorithms
with batch so it's V plus one is that
least like of optimal moreover no
algorithm can achieve a competitive
ratio better than half deterministic
randomized quantum yes with the same
constraint that the two were yes yeah so
you can't virtus batch vertices that are
too far apart but you know the future
when the other side
all right so in the next ten minutes I'm
going to give you the outline of the
proof of that a statement the proof is
actually not very difficult if I do my
job well and if you listen you know sort
of carefully hopefully by the end of ten
minutes you can at least know the
outline you can reconstruct there it's
gonna have three year steps one is that
I'm going to look at this optimization
this competitive analysis and reduce it
to a graph problem a graph covering
problem then I'll introduce two
amplification gadgets that say you only
need to do the analysis for a small and
that would give you something for large
and then from a small D to large D and
then once we establish this we only need
to look at small and and and a small B
for that we use a computer-aided
essentially linear programming based
proof notation for any graph H M of H is
its max weight matching value so that's
what I'm looking for if I have two
graphs if I write F a star H I mean the
product of the two graphs and in the
sense that let's say the two graphs have
the same set of vertices I'm gonna just
take the product of the weights I'll be
also having these operations are going
to be adding two graphs again with the
same vertices to each other or compare
two graphs there think of these as their
adjacent C matrices so when I say H 1
plus h 2 essentially I'm putting two
copies of this you know H for putting a
copy of H 1 on top of a copy of H 2 and
then H bigger than equal to G meaning
like if you have an edge here you
definitely have an edge there or the
number of edges between two vertices a
and J in H is bigger than or equal to
the number of edges between I and J in G
general graph
so why don't you have to tell us about
the ages
yes yeah so all enos you know let me
show you one construction and then it
will be clear so the graph that I'm
interested in are of this form so think
about the optimum solution the optimum
solution can match every vertex with the
vertices that arrived up to D steps
before and up to deer steps after so I
construct this graph in which for any
permutation connect every vertex to up
to D vertices before and up to D
vertices after now once you put the
weights here the maximum weight matching
in this graph is going to give you the
optimum solution so for any permutation
I get a different graph that looks like
that essentially optimum off line
connects the matching of this is the
optimum for that party note this is the
graph for that particular permutation
times G these are the weights the values
that you will gain from matching every
pair of vertices is that clear now
that's the performance of the matching
what about the batching graph
well batch essentially looks so you know
the if we look at the support graph of
batching it's a combination of as a
collection of complete graphs because
every D plus 1 it steps I look at all
these vertices and I find the maximum
weight matching here then again I find
the maximum weight matching after you
know 2 D plus the steps and so on so
essentially the performance of the
matching for a permutation is the
maximum weight matching in this graph
right so now what I have to do is I have
to compare the maximum weight matching
in this to between you know sort of
optimal matching and that
being numb like how far in magic ago
what's the rationale for that just
really short complexity or is that
constrained no it's like imagine people
are arriving one by one and request a
ride share and avoid sharing application
tell each one of them three minutes so
essentially when you arrive you can be
matched to vertices that are have up to
three minutes before you and up to yes
but yes definitely so let's say three is
a parameter it's like the quality of
service guarantee that we have for the
for the application so it's part of the
input
you know first based on some
calculations you decide to unhappiness
parameter yes so here's a you know one
question of maybe optimum can wait you
know dear steps what if I allow you a
little bit more can you do as well as
optimal it's like maybe I give batching
twice as much time can it do as well as
optimal it's a very nice question we
don't know how to answer that or either
this is actually an open problem I think
posed by Ola Svensson and we enjoyed it
for a couple of days we couldn't
I think it should be more than two days
oh well I'm telling you what I was there
for a week but Lausanne is beautiful so
we really didn't get enough time so here
is the trick that moves the problem from
you know the optimization to a graph
realm of optimization H 1 to H K is the
cover of the graph H if essentially if
you add the multiple copies of a choice
on top of each other you will get a
super graph so H is less than or equal
to H 1 plus h game I can also define a
fractional cover in which I take these
copies of the graphs multiply them to
some scalar essentially I get these
fractional edges and then I put them on
top of each other and I get a new graph
so I say if there exists Sigma 1 2 Sigma
K so these are permutations and this
scalar numbers lambda 1 and 2 lambda K
such that some of the lambda K is equal
to alpha and if you look at the batch
for these permutations this linear
combination covers the optimum for some
permutation let's say identity then
matching is 1 over alpha competitive
essentially it says if I look at you
know these different copies of the batch
for different permutations I can cover
the optimum graph then the maximum
matching I find in each one of these
copies or I can put them you know sort
of become a matching in the original
graph in the optimum graph so a simple
the linear combination of the maximum
weight matchings in this graph is bigger
than or equal to the maximum weight
matching here so now all I have to do is
that I can I have to take the optimum
graph and cover it with this batch
graphs and if I can find a small cover
found a good bound for the competitive
edge job I hope that's clear
now I'm going to show you these two
gadgets these two amplification gadgets
one that goes from a small and to lower
so we're gonna use these periodic
permutations we say a permutation is
periodic essentially it's repeating
itself plus P Morton and now I if I have
a periodic permutation for DN and so
instead of having it on a powerup now
I'm using a cycle because it just makes
things a little bit nicer and more
elegant but let's say you have some
permutation that repeats itself every D
you know every Pierre steps I can open
it up and I can repeat it so essentially
I can by repeating the pattern I can say
if I have a cover that's P periodic for
some n I can extend it to for some and n
prime if P divides N and n divides n
prime so essentially I can you know
amplify these are not you know they
don't exactly divide each other I will
have some loss but as an n prime becomes
bigger the losses is small so if you
look at the paper that is the more
complex the more complicated a statement
of this lemma but morally that's what's
going on now I can also use a similar
trick to go from a small D to large D by
vertex duplication so let's say I have
some cover
I duplicate every vertex or have
multiple copies of that and then it will
give me another cover this time for
larger D instead of larger and so again
the actual statement is a little bit
more detailed but it says a cover of the
contracted graph can be like a cover of
the original graph so you can go from a
small D to large D and the small loss if
D does not divide D prime so
since I have the amplification for a
small D to large D and a small end to
large and I can you know have an upper
bound on D let's say 50 and then try to
find the best cover it will be a linear
program now that linear program has
around 50 factorial variables so that's
that's a big linear program to solve but
there are some tricks to find you know
upper and lower bounds using the duo
solve it some work some groundwork I
should say we managed to found bound for
alpha be bigger than 50 bound lost
during - 2 7 9 that I told you about so
that's some bound probably you know if
you push 50 to 100 and do this a little
bit more carefully it can make it better
but the question that's more interesting
is whether you can just have there is a
more elegant solution so before I
so I've action over this place oh yeah
definitely so if you wanna stick
yourself to integral covers it becomes
problem becomes much harder so because
there is a lot of symmetry in the
solution the optimum solution has also
is not a unique optimal solution there
is a class of optimal solutions so then
you have to decide how you have the
patience but you know if the weights are
non zero then most likely when you look
for the maximum weight matching you
match everything to each other because
it's not two vertices that are left out
and the value of between them is non
zero you match that so then you're
talking only about parity of these I
don't think it makes a big difference
yes
and you try to help you see like for
some multiples of the if it's an end to
be called like some hospices did you try
to fly this like the LP key always gives
us two or sometimes
yeah so that's why I don't have like
conjecture you know this is it just
leave it as an open problem my guess is
that maybe for large enough n and large
enough D this is true it's up to you to
prove or disprove
Oh
so I talked about the random order motto
in which even though the graph was
arbitrary the vertices were arriving at
random in particular all the
permutations were equally likely let's
say I remove this restriction and the
vertices can arrive you know in some
adversarial order essentially there is
some adversity that decides the you know
what the graph looks like in every step
and it gives you a vertex gives you the
edges and the decisions of the adverts
that it could have been depend on your
algorithm what happens that so similar
model vertices arrive there you stay in
the system for dere steps you can match
them if they overlap if they are present
at the same time your goal is to find
the maximum rate matching in this model
the first observation is that not only
batching doesn't do well you know that's
poorly no deterministic algorithm can
get bound that competitive ratio so
think about V equal to 1 and n equal to
2 so you have these two vertices and you
can match them to each other and it will
give you a value of 1 you have to decide
whether you match these two to each
other or you know let go of this
matching and then you will have a chance
to match these two to each other let's
say you decide that you know you match
them then if X is very large you will
have a poor performance and if you don't
match them to each other and X is very
small again you will have a poor
performance so this tells you that no
deterministic algorithm can achieve
bound that competitive ratio and the
best thing you can do here is actually
to toss a coin with probably 50% match
them and 50% not much done so that tells
you no algorithm can achieve a
competitive factor better than 1/2
all right so now we give an algorithm
with a I'll show you an algorithm for
with the constant competitive ratio and
basically three ideas one is divide the
vertices randomly similar to the
argument I told you about the middle
vertex that you have to toss a coin with
probably 50% do versus one or another we
can I divide the vertices into two
thirds patient vertices and impatient
vertices patient vertices wait until the
very last minute until they are about to
depart then they get matched to
something in patient vertices they can
get matched somewhere in between their
arrival and departure and they get
matched to a patient vertex so when a
patient vertex is about to depart they
get match to it and that's a strictly
before their departure they're gonna
toss the coin for every single vertex
with probably 50% is gonna be patient or
it's gonna be impatient now if you know
which vertices are patient and which
vertices are impatient essentially you
have a maximum weight matching problem a
bipartite version of the problem that
you want to solve and there are
different ways to do that so for example
you can reduce it to the framework of a
line matching with free disposal or
there's actually you know a very nice
ascending auction algorithm with the
primal-dual analysis that gives you a
factor 1/2 so in that case the problem
is reasonably easy to solve now if I you
know coin at all if I toss the coin with
probably 50% and do it independently for
every single vertex the probability that
I get one edge right is 1/4 right I have
to decide the right way this one is
going to be impatient this one is going
to be impatient so I lose 1/4 here I
lose 1/2 here it will be like you know 1
over 8 that is a way to make this better
you can postpone this partitioning you
can make these decisions about who is
patient and who is not in a correlated
way so essentially you create patient
and impatient copies of each vertex you
make you postpone your decision until
the very last minute when the vertex is
about to depart you decide whether is
patient or impatient and then you work
by flipping a coin and then you
forget that decision like you know use
an alternating path to force the
decision of some other vertices so the
algorithm looks like this at the arrival
of vertex o create a patient copy create
an impatient coffee in a virtual graph
and that creates a bipartite graph in
which P is compatible with Q J if J is
less than I and every time match the pr2
QJ with the highest marginal edge rate
and then some R is about to leave
randomly match according to PI or Qi and
propagate the decision across the
alternating path and we can show that
this is 1/4 competitive so I showed you
a lower bound of 1/2 that all over but
that proper bound of 1/2 that upper
bound can be improved so the right
number is somewhere between these two we
don't know what it is so actually the
open problems are you know one is
batching half competitive as you
mentioned if batch to D plus one as good
as optimum of the best competitive ratio
on their diverse tell your model the
question of cost of waiting came up if
you have different vertices with
different sensitivity to wait 8 like you
know maybe somebody needs the right
immediately or needs a kidney
immediately come from a distribution how
do you change your decisions there
there's something that I'll talk about
more whether competitive ratio is
actually a good benchmark for looking at
the performance of these algorithms but
in my remaining what kind of a chair are
you ok ok so now I'm gonna use them only
another 5 minutes so I told you there
are interesting open problems in this
domain let me tell you my favorite one
it's a very simple very elegant problem
so imagine you know you have a bipartite
graph it's unweighted
the graph is given to you in advance and
even the left-hand side the a side is
when to you its present but the b-side
is generated sequentially and at random
so every time one vertex from B is
chosen and the probably that vertex are
you shows an is P I a vertex can be
chosen multiple time so the metrics are
Alves and then you have to decide
whether to match it or who to match it
to and this is how this happens G types
from time from one to T and again the
goal is to find the maximum weight
matching at the end very simple problem
right sort of the adversarial version of
that where the graph is not given to you
and the vertices that are one by one is
the you know online matching there is
this you know beautiful paper by Carla's
Iranian right you don't need that gives
you the one minus one over e the optimum
algorithm in the case where the arrival
is not adversarial comes from some
distribution we don't know the optimal
solution so I and some other people I
think I solve that here somewhere
have contributed to reducing the gap but
there is a gap now that's one question
and you know when you talk about the
competitive ratio of the problem but for
a problem that's online is stochastic
the notion of optimum online is
well-defined
if you give me exponential time I can
actually write a dynamic program that
would give me the optimum solution so
actually the question that we have is
computational you can ask what's the
computational complexity of the optimal
solution can be approximated is there a
difference between the approximation
ratio and the competitive ratio is there
any way to exploit this gap between
these two notions we don't know the
answer to any of these questions with
rod Ali and Nemo we looked at this
problem in the context of online
bayesian selection the profit inequality
and there there is actually a difference
at least for some special cases between
approximation and the competitive ratio
for online matching we don't know
also the computational complexity you
know here's the conjecture that the
problem is PS based complete the Class B
airspace is contains NP it's believed to
be much harder than
P and the conjecture is that it's
complete for that class I think it's the
D carrying team in this talk we don't
know how to prove that he is a problem
we can do so look at we call this the
right matching problem which is very
similar to what I just defined except
that the vertices have arrival time so
when you reach time T you look at all
the vertices whose arrival is exactly T
and then you choose them with
probability P I and then the algorithm
has to match it it's a slightly more
general version of the problem for that
the crystals we can prove that the
problem is PS based complete so this is
a reduction to the stochastic
satisfiability problem where in that you
know the vanilla version of the
satisfied to be affected by ability
problem you're given a boolean formula
and you're looking for an assignment of
true and false to satisfy the verb here
you have to give the values one by one
so you choose the value of x1 then x2 is
decided randomly with probability 50% x2
is true or false then you choose X 3 and
then X 4 is you know done randomly and
you're looking for an algorithm for
which the probability that the the
formula is at the end satisfied is more
than half that's the version of the PS
based complete problem that we reduced
the problem to so in order to give a
sense of the PS based completeness all
the partially observable Markov decision
problems are in peer space so
essentially this says this problem is at
least as hard as any palm DP problem on
the flip side the positive result is
that if the compatibility graph is
decided by Oakley Euclidean distances so
essentially your vertices are in some
grid and they're compatible if they are
within a certain distance then there is
a polynomial time approximation scheme
for the problem yes
yeah so when you look at the general
palm DP you can actually you know sort
of incorporate some finite state
machines so the reduction becomes
simpler here you can have an implicit
representation of the palm DP here since
the problem is combinatorial the
reduction is coming tutorial so you have
to actually build the gadget that
reduces to it
yeah that is actually the result of I
think papademetriou and sits across
Syria
alright good so to conclude early
problems in market designer my general
but you know sort of right sharing
applications in particular it give rise
to a lot of interesting problems in
algorithms and combinatorial
optimization think about rider pricing
driver pricing matching rights matching
riders to drivers matching rights to
each other
positioning drivers at scheduling routes
or determining routes in a static or
dynamic way for meat and large-capacity
vehicles they have a close connection to
classic problems like online matching
facility location and traveling salesmen
problems or the Bayesian selection
problem also known as profit inequality
problems so there is a tremendous
potential for having an impact think
about I think you know these
ride-sharing applications some because
know better than me have tens of
millions of rights per day so because of
the scale because of the granularity of
the data and because of low cost of
experimentation it's possible to come up
with new algorithms and troy de and see
if you know we can see improvements but
i think we need to take a second look at
our common are modeling practices and
you know standard paradigms for
evaluating performance of algorithms so
like you know in theoretical computer
science typically we do competitive
analysis the sense that we optimize
against an adversary that's going to
come up with the input and since that
verse that is determining the input
algorithm that the result is going to be
very conservative is going to make it be
very making very conservative choices
typically you know common practicing or
are is that you assume that your input
comes from some a stochastic process
there's a force on point process that
gives you the input and I think assuming
that the the rate of this ports on
processes can be predicted or even
measured and then there is like some
logit function that determines
the choice of the consumer and that can
also be measured is incredibly
optimistic so after looking at it you
know a little bit date on running a
bunch of experiments if I've learned one
thing it's that we need a new way of you
know sort of model and a second look at
our modeling choices and new ways of
evaluating the performance of algorithms
to come up with you know a new formal
way of evaluating those so that we can
come up with algorithms that are more
impactful in practice thank you yes sir
[Music]
so imagine the deep minus one comes in
the graph currently has a certain set of
weights right the vertices and different
matchings
you know you even have a maximum ash and
now the D plus one comes in yes that's
going to create a certain new maximum
different deeds that come in will create
different maximum the parameters are
that last one
yes very are going to change the maximum
value right so think that in
anticipation of that last one there's
going to be some distribution of course
I'm not taking over scaling things and
kind of Bayesian thought about this is
maybe some distributions of the maximum
value I could get a really shitty one
come in in which case if I would have an
ability to basically have a loss of I'm
gonna let someone die because on
expectation the next one that comes in
is when they increase the value of the
whole match by a lot in practice I know
it's being done I don't know if there is
a good modeling of that so yeah true
actually you know one of the challenges
it's when you have benchmarks that are
so loose like competitive ratio a lot of
different algorithms will look the same
but then when you look at it you know
and real data then this small bits of
infinite sort of information that you
can get about the future and and if
there are uncertain can impact your
decision now
and then in the end you will be able to
the answer is in practice yes in theory
I don't know of any
so you have to come so in the in the
random permutation model you have to
look at the competitive ratio because
the optimum online is not well defined
I'd like to unlearn a stochastic problem
with all of this problem that I you know
mentioned we don't know the optimum
solution for all of them we have some
approximate optimal for all of them
there is a gap I'm happy to tell you one
by one
what are the techniques but so I don't
see why the right sharing over or
whatever you should stick to three days
or whatever it is beyond the rest yeah
actually that number should depend offs
on the sparsity right so maybe if you're
in downtown Manhattan you know maybe
within a couple of minutes you will see
a hundred different potential matches
even the worst case model of course in
practice it's 12 minutes but it's not
three but for your algorithmic purposes
if you bounce and so on yeah absolutely
you know you get a difficult right
writer who's you know located somewhere
else you spend some more time on it yeah
I agree
and also you know again this comes to
the sensitivity to cost you know cost of
waiting even in the case of say you know
kidney matching some people need
immediately some people have some time
to you know to wait one hopes it's not
clear we can you add another parameter
you know the worst case can get worst so
when would you get to match a
competitive ratio the question is what
is up now right also presumably ssin
right so that's that's why it's not
clear when it gets all right thanks a
lot
[Applause]